and this made my blood boil quite a bit  yeah i don't know about you guys but  when i heard about this  days before this happened so we had 13  u.s soldiers killed by explosions just  outside kabul's airport there  and biden said at his press conference  that he had no regrets  thank you mr president um  there's been some criticism  even from people in your party about the  dependence on the taliban to secure the  perimeter of the airport do do you feel  like there was  a mistake uh made in that regard  no i i don't look um i think general  mckenzie handled this  question very well  ah  okay  sorry you think it is  well  yeah no regrets uh i get not 13 exact  regrets of the number of soldiers that  were dead you know 14 regrets if you  include his presidency